it was really special to be on that set
physical transformations happen all the
time in hollywood but which actors said
yes and which ones outright refused to
change every performer had their reasons
we're checking out 10 actors who did
change and 10 who outright said no no
matter what the consequence if you weigh
over 140 pounds as a woman in hollywood
that it
if you're on the screen it will hurt
people's eyes
number one
simulu's journey to chongqi started out
with a tacky backflip while he had some
martial arts experience and could be
pretty physical that wasn't exactly
gonna cut it in the mcu so in came
superhero physical transformation time
this was like the real deal the actor
went through the usual suspects strict
diet rigorous workouts intense martial
arts training and of course stretching
and the stretching that was by far the
most painful yeah we'd say simu
definitely put in the work number two
he did it but he wasn't so happy about
it the dieting was awful no stranger to
getting in shape hello spider-man
holland had never gone through such a
drastic weight loss losing 28 pounds is
a lot when you're already that tiny
physical aspects of what i have to do
i don't ever want to do again holland
was dedicated there's no question about
it but when the people he was working
with were tired of him being so grumpy
there'd be the occasion where i'd say to
my brother harry can i have a salad for
lunch please and he would come back with
a five guys like a double bacon
cheeseburger with fries and i just would
inhale it even with the occasional
burger holland achieved an incredible
physical feat
number three
it's time for jennifer with the red hair
my character kate dibiaski lawrence
hasn't always undergone transformations
that the production wanted but when it
came to embodying the astrophysics grad
student and don't look up she said yes
to the change kate is the type to
you know be fierce and
notice me
uh hear me roar
ratata kind of lady stark red hair blunt
bangs and an undercut she looks ready to
dive back into the hunger games while
the change was drastic it made sense for
her character
number four
he booked the part and then reality set
in second thought was
i have to now get in shape all jokes
aside kumail nanjiani took his role and
physical transformation very seriously i
wanted to gain a lot of muscle by the
way there was a pretty significant
reason behind it it was important to me
because i was the first like pakistani
superhero like in a mainstream hollywood
movie everything he did to achieve his
peak physique from those rigorous
workouts and nutrition approved meals
it was worth it and shockingly came a
bit easier than he anticipated
number five
this transformation was no joker when
time came to get ready to film dallas
buyers club leto went hard losing 30
pounds and at the end of the day he
wound up with an oscar i was already
very thin i may have got down to 112 or
13 or something leto who famously goes
method actually left the sets with his
costume on and went out in character
throughout the filming process doing
everything from taking a stroll to
picking up some groceries and the looks
he got in the stores i got three
distinct looks and they weren't the
kinds you'd want while the weight loss
can seem concerning leto has his reasons
for it it's not about the most weight i
can lose it's more to represent the
character and at the end of the day he
did just that in character leto is
totally unrecognizable
number six
need to become another person there are
prosthetics for that playing real life
journalist megyn kelly made for an
intricate visual transformation when
charlize theron filmed bombshell the
hard part of the character makeup is i'm
changing someone into another person a
detail-oriented and uncomfortable makeup
session before filming made their own
look incredibly like kelly cherry's
makeup took like two hours in half but
there were some downsides including the
fact that the extensive makeup meant the
actress could only blink with one eye
number seven
here and he's more than just a funny
face so i became famous in my late teens
and then spent most of my young adult
life listening to people say that i was
fat and gross and unattractive comedies
and goofy characters were the jonah hill
jam but after bouncing between different
weights hill took life by the horns and
opted to make the most drastic physical
transformation yet maniac was one of
jonah hill's more serious roles and the
actor felt he wanted to look the way he
felt the part should and decided to drop
45 pounds by changing his eating habits
and throwing in some workout time
number eight
no time to die more like time to diet
the goal was to make him the fittest 50
year old in the world and unsurprisingly
the bond actor pulled it off it's a
physical role and i get bashed up
wanting to do his own stunts meant craig
had to do the work to be in good enough
shape to safely bond around town a full
year of workouts with two week boot
camps sprinkled in every month and
dieting alongside constant training
during filming were key and all this
made it the most intense training the
actor had ever done for a bond movie
number nine
transformations on screen and off
joaquin phoenix does them all becoming
the joker involved losing an insane 52
pounds i've done it before i worked with
the same doctor before while phoenix
made sure to undergo the intense process
as safely as possible it still took a
toll on the actor mentally and
physically and you really develop like a
disorder i mean it's it's it's wild
honestly after playing joker we think
any actor would need some time to
recover
number 10
baywatch more like baywatch zac efron
was fit but he was nothing close to
baywatch fit before he filmed i don't
think i've ever quite trained as hard
physically say bye bye to carbs and
sugar and hello to gut-wrenching
workouts including over a thousand
repetitions of certain exercises per
session you're coming right out of your
trailer and have to look like that yeah
i'm an olympic athlete it wasn't easy
but he did it and this insane body
transformation was a major shift just
another day living that baywatch life
number 11.
do bats work out
no and neither does this batman instead
of dealing with physical training and
low carb diets pattinson wanted to focus
on looking strong the actor isn't a big
fan of the whole bulk up culture i think
if you're working out all the time
you're part of the problem you set a
precedent no one was doing this in the
70s he's got a point there it's early
batman so it's not he's not a huge
um
kind of bruiser number 12.
he's cool and chill as a cucumber until
it comes to a rough wig tom's a pretty
agreeable guy and has put the work into
preparing for his roles but when the
possibility of wearing a less than cool
looking wig was put on the table for no
way home holland put his foot down his
hair was shorter after cutting it for
another project and the producers on
spiderman expected the floppy-haired kid
to come back but holland felt too cool
to downgrade and when you're as famous
as holland it's a bit easier to get away
with that kind of refusal number 13.
superhero workout and diet she'll think
about it but no guarantees while she was
eager to join the team pugh needed to
get some details on what exactly the
marvel lifestyle entailed since she
wanted to have a say in what kind of
changes her body went through i didn't
want to be part of something where i was
constantly checked on and people making
sure i was in the right shape that's not
me at all early on in her career the
actress was pressured to lose weight and
it made her question having a career in
hollywood but she managed to stick to
what she wants i have a confident
playlist that i play whenever i need to
we love pew just the way she is elena is
a boss
no one can keep margot robbie away from
london pubs before she secured playing
jane in the legend of tarzan the
production was hoping she'd slimmed down
and robbie responded with a hot no
getting to film in london meant an
excellent pub scene and the actress
wasn't about to pass up on the
opportunity to really enjoy the city
logically she argued it didn't make that
much sense anyway after all and the era
that it takes place in it's like it
wouldn't have been fashionable for jane
to be stick thin anyway this jane wasn't
doing any juice cleanses or hit workouts
number fifteen
it might have been called the hunger
games but lawrence wasn't about to
starve for her role there was talk in
the pre-production stage about lawrence
thinning out a bit but the actress felt
really strongly that it wasn't the most
responsible image to put out there for
young girls to look up to and if she was
going to play a hero in the eyes of
teens around the world she wanted them
to know that they didn't have to adhere
to the hollywood standard wise words
from a wise woman
number 16.
she did it once but never again while
schumer has often been outspoken about
the unrealistic beauty standards in the
industry before filming train wreck she
found herself in a bit of a conflict and
ended up losing a drastic amount of
weight at the wish of producers but
doing it the producer's way once was one
time too many when pre-production for
snatched and i feel pretty came around
dieting was a hard no i lost some weight
to do that but um
never again number 17
no blonde no bond daniel craig has
undergone plenty of transformations but
when it came to losing his blonde locks
to embody bond and casino royale the
actor wasn't so ready to give in to the
request i was asked to dye my hair brown
to play this role but it was out of the
question even though most of the bonds
before him sported the brunette craig
wasn't into it and tried to compromise
even offering to cut his hair he got his
way in the end and the blonde turned out
not to be a problem at all he has
carried the bond torch for over a decade
after all
number 18
ready for a close-up these teeth aren't
exactly hollywood perfect filming the
first spider-man
one of the producers tried to subtly
coerce me into changing my teeth into
those perfect barbie teeth but dunst
wasn't into that plan
starting her career so young the actress
was lucky to have great role models like
sophia coppola who gave her the
confidence she needed to have an a woman
who i thought was so cool to look up to
think that i'm pretty like kind of set
me up for the rest of you know dealing
with hollywood let's be real changing
your teeth for one roll is pretty
drastic anyway so who can blame dunst
for passing on that one
number 19.
he was famous for it but no more if you
think tom hanks would lose or gain
weight for a roll again guess again
living with type 2 diabetes was the main
reason for cutting out the crazy dieting
since controlling the disease can be
done through a workout and diet hanks
wasn't willing to compromise on his
health anymore since it actually poses a
pretty significant health risk
number 20.
no matter how much you pay nothing's
gonna get rid of these curves sofia
vergara has made a killing in hollywood
cashing in some huge paychecks for her
work but none of that payment involved
losing any weight in her early acting
days producers didn't dig the curves and
she lost out on some jobs but that
didn't stop vergara from sticking to who
she was and embracing the body she was
in if that's what the role wants then
she doesn't want it whether or not they
underwent a huge transformation all
these actors managed to pull off their
roles which physical change did you
think was most intense
you